- We are so excited.
We just found out that our
favorite childhood lollies
have been transformed into ice cream.
So we're here today to try it.
We're ready, bring it on.
(upbeat music)
So this is Peppermint Crisp and as soon
as it was put in the bowl, I can smell it
and it smells like childhood.
- I'm really gonna enjoy
this, 'cause I like peppermint
and I like crisp and I like chocolate
and I like ice cream.
- Yes!
(laughter)
I feel this.
- That is so good.
- Cold toothpaste.
- Yeah.
- My grandma will go ape-shit for this.
- They totally pulled this off.
- Yeah, this is just like crazy delicious.
- So this is Milo, which is
like our version of Nesquick.
- It's kind of a flavor
that you don't ever forget.
(growls)
- Definitely got a strong Milo flavor,
but it doesn't have that texture
that you have when you
add Milo onto ice cream,
which I think I kind of miss.
- To be honest, this doesn't really taste
like Milo to me, this just
tastes like chocolate ice cream.
- I would eat this but I
would put Milo on top still.
- Yeah.
- Why can't we just buy ice cream,
put some Milo on it, mix it around,
and you know, save about five bucks?
- It's fine.
- Fantales are an iconic Australian lolly,
so I'm really excited for this.
- There's no quiz or anything
about Australian celebrities.
That's a missed opportunity.
That would've been fun.
- This is one of the ones that
you can't really fake at home,
so I'm pretty excited
they've done it for us.
- I feel like if a Caramello Koala
was ice cream, it would
be very much so like this.
- No, this is better than a
Caramello Koala ice cream.
- Tastes like they got their hands
on the Gaytime ice cream that
probably didn't sell great
and they were like,
what do we do with this?
- They definitely pulled this one off.
I just love Smarties.
I reckon they're so much better than M&Ms.
- I'm really not expecting much, though.
I'm probably expecting chocolate
- [Both] ice cream, with
- some chunks of Smartie in it,
which is just chocolate.
- Tastes like chocolate ice
cream with Smarties in it.
- You can easily just do this on the cheap
with cheap ice cream and real Smarties.
- To be honest, I'd rather just have
an M&M McFlurry.
- Because M&Ms are better.
- Fruit Tingles are just an
iconic part of your childhood.
So to have that in ice cream form
is just like a nostalgia hit.
- This is not something that I feel
you can really do at home.
- This just tastes like
straight happiness.
- Tastes like the ice cream
version of those bananas.
- Yellow is definitely the worst
Fruit Tingle flavor and that's
what I'm getting in this.
So I'm not into it.
- I just feel with this one
they could've maybe tried
a bit harder to make the ice cream
taste like a Fruit Tingle.
- Like, actually taking Fruit Tingles
and like turned that into ice cream.
Not just adding Fruit
Tingles to ice cream.
- Yeah!
- Like, well, really
Fruit Tingles weren't made
to be turned into an ice cream.
That's a bad idea.
- After today, I really
feel like I got reminded
with a lot of childhood flavors.
But I kinda feel like I
was taken down that road
in a cheats way.
- Some of them worked, some didn't.
- It's okay, but I feel
like you could just
do a cheap version at home.
(upbeat music)